a fox she's a busy woman these days
but like so many of her hollywood peers
the world stopped when viveka learned
about the loss
of one of her idols the legendary miss
cicely tyson
ms tyson you know we just miss you the
woman lived a remarkable life didn't she
wow i just remember meeting her
and feeling like being in the presence
of
royalty and i cried and these tears that
i shed now are tears of joy
because may we all live as full of a
life
as the late grace city tyson did
vivica met miss tyson 16 years ago
in fact the two shared a passion for
giving back
both walking in 2009's red dress
collection
we've teamed up with vivica and the
american heart association's
go red for women movement to introduce
their new campaign
how it started and how it's going this
year because we can't do it the fashion
show because of covid
um all the girls that ripped the runway
back in the day they're going to do
how it started and now how how is it
going so
this is my little sneak peek as you can
see biblica still holding it together
y'all
are still doing the time right watch out
ma'am watch out
[Music]
really to find out that one in three
women will die
from heart disease is just tragic so
i'm glad that we're bringing out you
know recognition and letting
women know to make sure that you take
care of your heart so vivica this friday
is national
wear red day and of course this is
supporting the american heart
association
go red for women movement yes to all my
ladies out there rock your red girl
you got it viv what a great cause and
you better believe that all of us here
at et
will be rocking our red on friday to
show our support
you